what was the heaviest you ever weighed
587 pounds is ridiculous I was such a
tremendously large dude I was in a
wheelchair for everything I did had to
go to the doctor's office wheelchair and
sometimes even at home I had to pull the
wheelchair out just to get around my
house one of the reasons my marriage
failed is because my wife became my
caretaker I was literally having to help
me from the chair in the bed I know what
he wants to do that am I right and
thinking that you were diagnosed with a
form of cancer yeah I have polycythemia
vera most people who die from it will
die on an average about 20 years from
their diagnosis
podcast